hi
welcome to my talk on how to guarantee
your machine learning model
is going to fail on first contact with
the real world
my name is jasper ramsch and i'm a
machine learning engineer
i have experience building deep neural
networks on satellite data
subsurface geoscientific data
i really like to work on kaggle
notebooks
and share like more simpler models like
random forests and
yeah i've also successfully worked on
some hackathon projects so
i i really like machine learning like
from supervised to unsupervised
shallow deep like it's fascinating
but today we're going to have a bit of a
look
at a different dimension of machine
learning
while all of this is a bit
tongue-in-cheek
it's very important to see that in
real world applications there's nuance
so
you'll have to see that sometimes
you actually have to do some of this to
make it work
first one easiest one 99
accuracy now what does that actually
mean
in this case it well out of thousand
samples
two are only wrong and that usually
means that you're not
really dealing with real world data
you're probably
dealing with a very clean data set real
world data is messy
this is one of my favorite examples
those are blueberry muffins and
chihuahuas
and even humans have problems telling
them apart be it label noise
like mislabeling something or be it
actually
having really complicated data 99
accuracy is rarely achievable on real
world applications
some of the stuff that we have to do
which usually
gets our metric a little bit lower is
data augmentation so
this cute animal if you only train it on
the original data
then your machine learning model for
wildlife cameras or whatever you're
doing
is gonna have a problem if it's getting
up and close
um really inspecting the camera your
neural network will not understand that
unless you train it to usually
that means that your metric evaluation
is
getting a bit lower that's why on kaggle
for example we often train
all the epochs with augmentation and
then as a trick
the last epoch is going to be trained on
the original data
to kind of get the variability in the
data but then
kind of fit like fine-tune your your
network
on the yeah on on that peak of the
probability distribution
to really have your model crash and burn
you have to
absolutely ignore overfitting and data
leakage
overfitting just to recap is the idea
that
you have some kind of underlying model
the true data so
in this regression model right here we
have a polynomial of degree 4 it does a
really good job of approximating this
data
now a linear model is too simple to
really
capture the variability and the
complexity of your data
but the degree the 15 degree
model is well it captures
every data point in the training set but
if you give it new data this new data
will not fit on the prediction
so what that means in this trough right
here
or in this peak right here
you actually have massive errors just
because your model is much too complex
and
overfit on your data data leakage is
something that um
not enough people know about actually
and it's something that i learned on
kaggle this satellite data was supposed
to identify
either ships or icebergs in the sea
and the problem was these the icebergs
were all taken from one acquisition
so the incidence angle was similar for
all of them
so actually the winning solution ended
up
using mostly that feature to predict
um predict the right outcome and win
a significant amount of money with a
model that was
absolutely useless on real world days
you may be thinking okay but
what's the point well in hackathon
i had that problem with my own data in
the data cleaning process we forgot to
take out one column
and that column was actually directly
predictive
of our labels so we had data leakage
in our in our model and it was
performing really well
and we realized that and we had to do
the entire data processing again because
we forgot
to take that out to be really careful
and
it's usually a manual process like the
machine learning model isn't going to
tell you oh this feature this feature is
essentially your output feature
like you have to really dig in and do
your job as a data scientist to make it
really crush and burn
you have to assume everything is iid
what's iid
basically it means your data is
independent
and identically distributed every data
point
is generated independent of each other
data point
and that the distribution of these data
points
is identical for all data that you get
now in the real world unfortunately
so well my my background is geoscience
so
we'll have a quick look at rocks in the
real world a lot of data depends on each
other
so for example this beautiful mountain
range right here
exists because rocks were deposited on
top of each other
and that deposition is usually dependent
on the rock before
and the identical distribution is
another problem in these rocks you can
see some layers
some very interspersed layers very thin
layers
are different than the other you have
that a lot class imbalances
and the problem with a lot of machine
learning
is they assume iid and that means
the machine learning model will quickly
learn in this case
that predicting green we'll get it 70
there so we have like 45 000 green
25 000 non-green and if you just take
the accuracy of that
your machine learning model is shifting
the standard case to be
just the green and that's usually not
good
to make your model really really bad
just use accuracy
it's good it works well it doesn't
for imbalanced data a lot of times so
basically what you
want to look at is the f1 score
and definitely the roc auc curve
so the area under curve because those
are exceptionally good at explaining
how the decision is made looking a
little bit more into
false positives and false negatives what
you do
is you choose a loss function that is
appropriate
and um yeah basically models
the true costs of your data in neural
networks
when we do semantic segmentation so when
we find objects
in our images self-driving cars are
using
exactly this this segmentation to
basically say
this is the lane there's a bike over
there and that's all
by doing the outlines and the
classification
of your images that are taken so for
this you have a lot of different
choices of metrics as well
the iou is a classic where essentially
you're aligning these maps with the maps
where you know it's supposed to be
the cross entropy is always doing quite
well which is also used in
classification
knowing what you need them for is
sometimes really important
but also just trying what works this is
a classic
and it's a contentious topic um
collecting more data
we're living in a big data world these
days
we're talking about petabytes at this
point exabytes
like these huge amounts of data data
isn't
equal to ground truth but let's have a
look at
cern those are the the people that
invented the internet
and are the physics researchers of our
times
what they do is they throw away most of
their data
they do these collisions of protons
and collect all this kind of data but
they know
what data they're looking for so this
data
is already heavily filtered when it goes
on the hard disk
because if they even even with the data
they're collecting
that's at 25 gigabytes per second
they have hundreds of petabytes of data
already after filtering it
and the amount of data they would have
without filtering is just
it would just not be possible not
physically and not technologically
possible to collect um
so thinking that data is ground truth
is already faulty in physics geophysics
data is interesting because you have so
many
things influencing it and in the end you
for every use case you have you have to
reprocess the data
so do a different pre-processing before
you do interpretation and whatever you
do with geophysical data
going more into the social side of
things
taxonomies how you classify things
um are often decided by people
beforehand
and like one of the more morbid
taxonomies in imagenet
something all of us are using is
the person class has a subclass called
loser and failure where there's a kid
with
shades in there like sunglasses that's
not great
and if we go to a the gpt2 model
which is the last um openai model gpd3
is now the
latest one that they have but gpt2 was
trained on mostly reddit data
so they went through reddit and had a
look at all different links
and the problem is there's a lot of
conspiracy theories on reddit
so if you actually ask it about
geoscience a lot of times you will get
answers pertaining to a flat earth
for example and that's not great reusing
these models that were
trained from a data source that is
unscientific for example
like this is the case can be really
problematic
just collecting more data like
getting more reddit comments is easy
people are writing these every day
every second there's new comments
but it may not be the highest quality
source of information that you can get
strategies that
sometimes work is if you have human
interpretations
so for example on medical data you
often ask radiologists to do x-ray
interpretation you want multiple people
to
interpret the same image because even
though it's
kind of it's kind of the same thing the
interpretation
varies from person to person and what's
interesting also
is that interpretations vary
from yourself to yourself so really good
data sets
go back to the same person six months
later a year later
and have them reinterpret the same data
so you have this
inter and intra interpreter variability
in your data set captured
that's how you get good human
interpreted
data another thing that you can do is
question and maybe change questionable
taxonomies
like the loser one have a look into this
and don't accept this as what it is i
think we all can do better
and we all can make this world a little
bit nicer even though we're
just a data scientist just using this
and um if you do want to collect more
data to get
better results don't go to the same
sources
so in my example of doing
satellite image classification
right now we're collecting data and
basically
what we decided to do is collect data in
as
many different positions
in the country as possible so we get a
representative sample
instead of just more data because if we
have a lot of data from the same area
we get really good at that area but
basically we have no idea of what's
really happening in all the other places
cross validation
we all do validation right we have to
it's the only way for us to know that
our model is actually doing anything
significant
now cross validation is taking this a
little step further
but um it's absolutely necessary like
actually necessary um no joking here
to build good models if you do not do
cross validation
your model is probably not performing
well
and how that works is you split your
training data
in different folds and train on all
except one
and do that all the way around like if
you just do random sampling
you have the same problem as before with
the
imbalance data so what we do there
is stratifying so right here you see
our smallest class is still split up
in four parts in this case the medium
class
also four equal parts so we really make
sure that
even in each fold right here we have
a representation of all distributions
which goes back to iid
right we want this to be identically
distributed
so all our classes have to be present
in all of our faults for the cross
validation
it's very important and stratification
really good to maybe make our model not
crash and burn
we have the identical distribution now
looking at
independence time series there's always
a dependence in time
we have one data point the next data
point depends on the data point before
so in time series we can do a time
series split
so basically always predict the next
step
the next time epoch going back to
geographical data
and geoscience data this data is always
somehow correlated in space so
if i have my satellite data if i were to
just pick
random samples out of that that would
mean that
i get a lot of samples in the training
set that are
right next to data in my validation set
which is kind of cheating because
they're basically next to each other
look back to the mountain range
if i if i get points that are even 10
50 meters apart that means i'm basically
predicting on my training set
so what we do instead of doing the
random splits
is that we do blocks and we do cross
validation across blocks a lot of times
we have to do cross validation on our
pre-processing
there have been cases in biostat
statistics where published research
was found to actually have null results
when the preprocessing was included in
the cross validation
so basically the data was
unintentionally probably
hand-picked in a way that there was then
the signal in the data which actually
wasn't there
always include your your pre-processing
steps your data selection steps
in the cross-validation really important
tips for doing cross validation right
but cross validation isn't enough
cross validation is only a noisy
estimate of your prediction error
and it highly depends on the number of
samples that you have
if you only have hundred samples which
often is the case we don't have that
many data especially in science
that means our confidence interval is
18 so really nine percent on each side
of of our our cross validation score
could still be a valid score so if we
get a 90
it might be somewhere between 81 and 99
of accuracy in this case and even if we
have 10
000 samples which already um goes to the
to the limit of
a lot of the more simple methods we
still have
almost two percent error on our estimate
of our loss in the cross validation so
despite doing cross-validation
especially when we think about kaggle
where
a lot of times you are winning by 0.001
so it's really just getting another
sample right and this
is not a case where cross validation is
getting you anywhere this is just
sheer luck you absolutely have to ignore
model simplicity
this is an example where they used a
deep neural network to predict
earthquake aftershocks and i love this
paper it was a
collaboration between harvard and google
it got
published in nature the problem is
another earthquake scientist as
seismologist
has basically gotten the same result
with a single neuron with
logistic regression so really always
look for an analysis if
a simpler model can do and that means
having a dummy classifier i mentioned i
love
scikit-learn right they have this dummy
classifier which is essentially a coin
flip but a smart coin flip
with as many sides as you need and class
imbalance in there
fit a linear model and usually fit a
random forest because
they are really good having those models
in the on the back burner to
back up your more complex models is
usually a very important step to crash
and burn
you always want to trust
counter-intuitive results
carl sagan said it really good
extraordinary results
require extraordinary evidence and even
more so in my opinion
on machine learning tasks now
let's get into it because there's
a lot of questionable applications now
like predicting your face from voice
where they're like yeah but we only want
the general phase which is
um problematic
[Music]
or this startup that is
making hiring decisions based on video
and like even even the washington post
is writing outside experts call it
profoundly disturbing
and i agree with them because over the
years
again and again and again all these
systems that do facial recognition
have shown bias against especially
gender minorities so often women
and racial minorities
so people of color have often been
disadvantaged in here
most recently seen in the zoom feature
and
twitter uh showing more white people
than
people of color in the in the focus
selection of images
so not great and there's a lot of
research into this
these videos and the tutorial on
fairness by
uh gabriel are really interesting so
if you do research on that affects
humans
you probably want to have a look into
bias in machine learning so really
have a look at these a lot of decisions
have unfortunately reinforced
a lot of bias that we have in society
and i don't think that's necessary we
can
really work together to have a more
equitable
future and talking about these experts
we also have experts in physics so a lot
of times data scientists come up with
these
wonderful models but they have
non-physical results so
explaining that is is quite easy to a
physicist
i don't know if i can do it as well on a
um on a layman's
group but essentially the idea is that
if you have
observations then these observations can
oftentimes be explained
by multiple different explanations
by multiple processes that would
generate this data in
machine learning this is
just as true so your machine learning is
just a
big um big gradient descent
and it's a non-convex gradient descent
so um well at least from neural networks
and that means it might there
there are different minima where your
machine learning model might end up and
that means your machine learning model
might find
one of one of the many explanations
for your data explainability shows how
machine learning model thinks
explainability
is really important in my um in my
opinion
but it can lead you down the wrong path
so having a look at the
confidence of neural networks can be it
can be really funny
because on the top left the neural
network is
99 confident that that is a sea lion
and on the bottom right that is clearly
not a jigsaw puzzle the problem with
explainability right there is
that explainability will explain to you
why the neural network thinks it comes
to this conclusion
so first of all getting from these 99
neural networks a lot of really good
machine learning
models are quite confident in their
prediction
so what we want to do is use calibration
to actually get them to a number that
reflects reality a little bit more so
ideally we want linear
calibration on our models and
i love scikit-learn did i mention that
they
have a cross-validation
method for calibrator classifiers
which can calibrate your random forest
um can calibrate your svm
and those models while being really
powerful
you cannot use the the um
well the predicted probabilities as a
confidence value
just like you can't do it really on
these neural networks
now sharp for example is a
library for explainability it's an
amazing library
i really love it it's been published as
a nature paper
and the idea is that you have your black
box model
and shap can then calculate the
impact of each variable to your output
and while that's great the methods used
in that will explain to you why it came
to the decision
even if the decision is wrong so
it doesn't really tell you causal
information
but rather correlational information why
it came to this
conclusion that's kind of the divide
between explainability
and interpretability so explainability
with
sharp partial dependence plots lime
feature importance really great methods
but they are post hoc methods so after
you've done your training
after you've done your model fit you can
then have a look at
how this model explains its decision
but that doesn't mean that this model
has any
idea of causality for that we have to go
to interpretability which are often
bayesian methods
linear models and things like
explainable forest cause
causal trees as well and rule fit to
make your model
crash and burn you have to assume your
machine
learning model can outperform your
assumptions and baseline data
this may be a little bit abstract but
let me try to explain it in a way with
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning often uses
environments to find something to learn
something to teach a robot
now the environment the
the robots can only get as good as the
environment
so there's for example a tetris
reinforcement
experiment where at some point
the the agent the robot figured out that
if the robot pauses the game right
before it would lose
it never loses so it can only get
as good as the game environment is
and this is also true for a lot of other
machine learning models
so one application that i was working on
can extract data with a base model
that uses correlation so you correlate
two time series to each other and look
at the shifts and those shifts are
sometimes what you want but those are
1d correlations and my data is actually
in 3d
so when i use these 1d predictions
in a neural network which can predict in
3d
i still have this bias or this
information
baked in as the assumption in my neural
network
that this 1d information this 1d
extraction process gives me so really
when you do this kind of work especially
in a scientific
application you have to be absolutely
careful how you generate your data
and what um sort of
what sort of modeling assumptions you
put into your data
now for the speed round when your
machine learning model
isn't scoring perfectly you can still
spice up the results
cherry picking cherry picking is really
common
in natural language processing where you
just
generate a bunch of sentences and for
your paper you pick the ones that look
best
on images you pick the ones that are
most interesting so it gets published it
is
quite common to overfit your method
on the benchmark so that your method
looks more important there's a really
interesting paper linked
which basically has a look if imagenet
classifier is actually
um generalized to imagenet
and they found that a lot of cases
it is not the case the inverse crime
is something from math and physics which
essentially states that you cannot
um use the method
to invert your data the same thing to
find the underlying
information that generated the data so
if we know the generation process
of some data source you cannot use that
same process to
get back to your causal information that
is the inverse crime because you already
know
this is working backwards and forwards
one of my favorite ones
measuring what is easy instead of what's
meaningful
and step counters are one of those
things step counters have more of a weak
correlation to actual fitness
whereas like heart rate variability has
a really good correlation
but heart rate variability is much
harder to collect
also quite common in machine learning
where
some classes are just really easy to
label whereas
the harder classes the really
interesting
classes as well are often well
a little bit neglected to absolutely
make sure
your model is guaranteed to fail
on contact with the real world
use nothing else but accuracy under no
circumstances
shall you spend time on validation like
your model is going to be fine blindly
trust counter-intuitive results
counter-intuitive results are amazing
immediately
go to the press that you found the
newest
best ai in the world and explainability
is overrated if you use it
it perfectly explains everything it's
kind of a shredding is explainability
and of course take all the points that
are made here as gospel
so thank you for listening i hope you
found this insightful
i had a lot of fun and i'll see you in
the q a